[Musique]
que j'en ai du patrimoine ça permet
d'aller dans des lieux on n'a pas
forcément l'habitude d'aller et de
découvrir des choses qu'on n'aurait pas
forcément fait dans notre quotidien
de ce qui est contenu à l'intérieur
parce que l'extérieur ne reflète pas
vraiment ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur avec
ces trésors de peinture de tableaux de
fresques d'arabesque etc c'est
absolument somptueux
c'est super de voir directement où
est-ce qu'il travaille leur bureau à
disposition des pièces ou est-ce qu'il
circule c'était très intéressant de voir
concrètement ce qu'ils font à
l'intérieur du bâtiment
[Musique]
je pense que c'est important que tout le
monde essaye une fois dans sa vie de
passer au Sénat enfin ou à l'Assemblée
nationale parce que
les lois c'est quelque chose qui nous
impactent au quotidien et que finalement
c'est intéressant que tout le monde
sache comment ça fonctionne et dans quel
endroit tout ça c'est voté
finalement on se pose beaucoup de
questions sur le Sénat le fonctionnement
est pas aussi facile d'accès que pour la
Chambre des députés donc je me suis dit
bah c'est intéressant voilà j'ai
découvert toute l'histoire de sa
création voilà et non franchement c'est
intéressant vraiment intéressant